[Music]
[Music]
sing it the titans have soft rock yachty
crew are ready to reel you in this
weekend as they perform at chaos at the
palms and joining us now is lead singer
philly ocean and guitarist tommy bowie
welcome you guys hey thanks so much for
having us i love you guys already just
look alone you're all set ready to go
that's right you kind of see the look
and you immediately know what you're in
for you kind of get it you know it's a
vibe well okay some of our interns i was
talking about yacht rock and some of our
interns said to me what is yacht rock
yes so for those that are familiar with
yacht rock what is yacht rock so the the
way i like to describe it is you already
know what it is you just didn't know it
was called yacht rock
it's all of the
soft rock hits from the late 70s early
80s toto africa kenny loggins michael
mcdonald holland oaks yes goes on he's
preaching to me
exactly the greatest songs you know
they're they're in the cultural
zeitgeist you've been singing them for
30 years 40 years you know and and
they're amazing and they just put a
smile on your face they do and yacht
rock is a thing now you can go to
siriusxm yacht rock is one of the top
stations right on siriusxm right now
people eat this stuff up do you have a
favorite song that you guys perform i
mean i really like heart to heart by
kenny loggins
kenny logan has an amazing voice and
it's such a cool song and it's kind of
like a little bit jazzy and rock and
roll at the same time so it's got those
jazz chords in it yeah it's got a great
bridge uh one of my favorites uh is
fooled around and fell in love by elvin
bishop which is one that we don't play
all the time but when we do people go
off how does that one go how does
everyone go
and fell in love yes you heard it it's
it right there and then christopher
cross sailing is that the poster child
when it comes to
yeah that's one of the big ones for sure
and yeah you know it's a big moment in
the show when we do that oh isn't that
that's the big number yeah well it's one
of them you know we don't get their
phones out they have their lights on
waving back and forth it's great and
that's one of the best things about what
we do is how intuit our audience members
get they show up dressed like this they
show up wearing captain's hats
it's amazing and it's a whole thing and
you guys have the look as well yeah
what's a yacht rock after party like
well is
i mean margaritas you know and i mean
we have a new song out it's called sex
on the beach yep that's great drinking
yeah that's kind of our band name you
can stream uh sex on the beach our new
single on spotify and all the streaming
platforms we tried to emulate kind of
the vibe and the feel of these classic
70s and 80s soft rock songs and it was
mixed by uh industry legend chris lord
algae now um
we talked about your favorite songs that
you guys saying uh i feel like yat rock
even when you when you talk to the crowd
is there kind of like a
a i don't know like a a tone you should
have when you dress the crowd like hello
everyone like how does john rocker speak
you know we
i'm not much different than how i do now
honestly but it's just it's the end it's
really all about the energy and the
relationship with the audience
everybody's there to be in on it with us
they get the vibe already and we're just
about bringing an enthusiastic energetic
performance to these songs it's not it's
not a boring soft you're not up there
just playing some music you're you're
energized playing songs are up there
putting on a show for everybody there's
lights there's choreography
you're going to see it there's a
of yacht lucretia that's right can i put
you on the spot can you give me a little
bit of sailing before we wrap up
well it's not far down to paradise at
least that's not for me
and if the wind is right you can stand
away
find serenity
oh the can't scan new miracles just you
wait and see
believe
me
i mean he sounds just like christopher
cross man thank you guys so much that's
awesome i appreciate it you guys are
fantastic yali crew will be performing
at chaos at palms casino resort this
saturday tomorrow night there are still
tickets available through ticketmaster
and if you're looking to celebrate the